hi everyone in my last video I spoke
about some of the books I would
recommend for learning physics and that
video seemed to be well received some of
you liked and agreed with some of the
recommendations and you had some of your
own one comment that I saw was from
someone who recommended the advice and
book lists of someone called John Bayes
now John Bayes is a mathematical
physicist who works in America and he
works on some pretty cool and abstract
ideas and physics including loop quantum
gravity now why I found this comment
really interesting was because John
Bayes actually has a few really good
websites for people wanting to learn
physics or maths and he even gives some
advice and tips around the idea of how
do you choose between physics and maths
if you're interested in both of these
areas so today I was going to do I guess
a bit of a follow-up video to my last
one and just talk about some of the
advice from mostly the pages of John
Bayes and kind of encourage you to go
and check out these links yourself for a
lot more comprehensive information about
books and advice for becoming a
physicist now I've got my laptop here
and one of I think the most useful pages
that will be the first one linked is by
John Bayes and it's how to learn math
and physics so he obviously has a lot of
experience because he is an established
academic at this point a lot better than
my advice I guess as just a PhD student
he talks about the idea of first
learning the basics of physics before
you can work up to something like
quantum mechanics black holes all the
sort of cool things that attract people
to physics in the first place without
the fundamental understanding of what we
know about physics and how the simple
things work you will actually find it a
bit difficult to tackle some of these
ideas I'll go into the book
recommendation soon John basis you can't
just learn math and physics by reading
books you have to do lots of
calculations yourself or experiments if
you want to do experimental physics
textbooks are full of homework problem
and it's good to do those it's also
important to make up your own research
topics and work on those so I guess
that's something to keep in mind if you
are really interested in something and
you even want to be a researcher in that
field there's nothing really stopping
you from devising your own questions and
going out to seek specific answers to a
question of your own you don't just have
to work through chapters and textbooks
doing problems without any of your own
sort of self direction he says that
taking courses and math and physics are
good because you get to hear lecturers
meet students and professors and do some
of the things you otherwise wouldn't
like work your butt off now this is sort
of true because I don't think I would
have ever learnt as much physics as I
did on my own because I guess I wouldn't
have pressed to go through with those
really difficult assignments those are
some things that I really needed a
support group of friends around me and
we needed to stay up all night together
working out there's one particular
integral I probably would have never had
the motivation to do that on my own so I
feel like that's only the real advantage
to courses is that you're forced to
finish things and do things that
otherwise would have been too difficult
on your own as another alternative to
just reading books he recommends going
through question-answer websites like
physics tech exchange physics overflow
and the same equivalents for math now
let's get on to his sort of book
recommendations he has five areas of
physics which he considers the
cornerstone topics and in roughly this
order he thinks you should learn them
classical mechanics statistical
mechanics electromagnetism special
relativity and quantum mechanics those
are the cornerstones and then once you
know these you can move on to things
like general relativity and quantum
field theory as he gets into
recommendations for books some of them
are similar to ones I mentioned last
week but there's a few that I missed or
forgot to mention one of them is for
classical mechanics he recommends
Goldstein and I actually have read a
little bit of that that
as well so I'd say that's good and it's
one that I missed another one that I
missed last week and that was also
pointed out in a comment was Schroeder's
thermal physics I do remember using that
book and it's a good one
so I would rather than reading out his
entire list of books I'd really urge you
to go and check out this list if you
were interested by some of the books I
shared last week
other notable things that I missed out
were kept Thorne's books there's a lot
more books here on relativity general
relativity cosmology and gravitation and
he also covers string theory which I
didn't give any recommendations for last
week and then he talks about all his
recommendations for math books this is
actually what I'm hoping to do in one of
my next videos maybe the next one that
comes out I'm gonna go through and show
you some of my books for learning
mathematics but if you want a heads up
check out his list here so that's one
more source of advice on how to learn
physics and maths but john bayes also
has a page on this website called advice
for the young scientist and here he just
talks about a few things like how to
keep your soul pursuing science he talks
about that even though now he works on
this quantum gravity which is sort of
quite a abstract idea but of an
ambitious thing to tackle he he couldn't
start with that he had to start his
academic journey with studying more
popular or fashionable topics I guess
because to make his way to becoming a
tenured professor and to study the
things he really found interesting he
had to get a lot of publications out
first and he had to do the research that
was fashionable and that he knew he
could write grants for and get grants
because getting grants and writing
papers are sort of what you're measured
as and that's how you end up in the
position here's where you can get paid
to work on whatever you want to up until
that point it's a little bit of a arms
race in terms of
keeping up with other researchers and
keeping up with what's popular
here's more practical tips for a young
scientist include going to a prestigious
school and working with the best
possible advisor the the idea of um
going to a prestigious school I guess is
something I also like to talk about more
in depth in the future I don't think
that going to the most prestigious
school is really that advantageous
especially for undergraduate but this
advice he's giving applies in the
context of graduate school and a postdoc
I guess at that point going to a school
and working with a good advisor gives
you the advantage of having someone who
is heavily connected into academia can
find connections for you and I guess
it's that name association if you've
worked with something someone that's
really respected people might respect
your work as well until they know more
about you and till you set up a name for
yourself but I guess I he's put it as
number one on his list of practical tips
I don't necessarily agree but that's
just my opinion and I think you can find
a good teacher a good supervisor or
someone that's well-connected without
necessarily going to the most expensive
or prestigious school you can I guess
find really smart people anywhere you
live and if if you work with someone
like your supervisor really well I think
that's more important than just going
after someone's name especially if you
go after someone that's like a really
famous or popular supervisor they might
not even have much time for you so I I
don't think is necessarily the most
important thing you should look for
number two is published papers here is
talks about how you should publish on
things that are fashionable at the stars
they get cited and that helps you
establish yourself it's not not really
controversial or unknown at all that
publishing in the world of academia is
sort of how it moves forward it's like
the publish or perish thing you need to
be
sharing your research with other people
and that's sort of I guess the currency
in the academic world number three on
the list is go to conferences I agree
with that go into conferences I've been
to a couple during my PhD it's like you
get to meet people and you get to see
the research that's going on and more so
than the interest you get from listening
to other people's talks and seeing their
posters is you actually get to meet
people and establish connections and
collaborations with them I think that is
really valuable he talks about the
importance of going giving good talks if
you are aspiring to be a scientist
I guess slow people don't consider
science to be a discipline where you
need to communicate a lot but it
definitely is giving good talks at a
conference it makes you seem come across
very favorably and if you're there to
meet people in connect with people you
want to make a good impression by giving
a really good conference talk I guess
it's also going to help you if you want
to pursue being a lecturer or teaching
at the University okay so he gives a few
more links on where to go for more
advice and then he finishes with this
paragraph called math or physics now
john bayes is a mathematical physicist
he's sort of on the interplay between
these two fields so I think his advice
is well-placed in terms of making this
sort of decision essentially he says no
one can stop you from learning and
thinking about both math and physics you
should definitely do both if you want to
the real issue is deciding whether you
want to work in a math department or in
a physics department it's possible to
switch between the disciplines like
after grad school or after you've done a
PhD but I think it becomes a lot harder
the further you go along so ideally you
want to make this sort of decision
before going to grad school whether you
want to be classed inside the math
department or inside the physics one I
guess some of the obvious advice is to
talk to as many mathematicians and
physicists as you can you can just like
walk around and the whole
University and knock on people's doors
like I've done this before and pretty
much all the time they're willing to
talk to you if you just have like
questions about what their day-to-day
life is like just go straight to the
source and ask any professors that you
can sort of get access to their opinion
on this matter in essence the difference
is that mathematicians get promoted by
publishing in math journals and for
physicists they get promoted by
publishing and physics journals so what
you should do is spend some time
browsing both math and physics journals
and see which one you would like to sort
of fit into which one you find more
interesting and could imagine publishing
in yourself so some of the examples
given are for purely like physics based
journals it's like Physical Review or
Physical Review Letters and for the
purely mathematical journals there's an
owl's of mathematics and transactions of
the American Mathematical Society you
can see that they are sort of from
different worlds in the way that they
type and the way that they communicate
ideas mathematicians typically write
like definition theorem proof style type
papers while physicists write shorter
ones packed with formulas but usually
leaving out the details of the
calculations I think in essence physics
is a faster
looser more energetic discipline this is
what John Bates is as well you have to
think about whether you would prefer
math and to think about things in a more
rigorous ground-up way as opposed to
physics where it's a little bit more
based on a physical intuition to find
the answers please go and check out
these links yourself all I can do is
sort of summarize them for you but I
can't read out every word so thanks for
the people that left comments on my last
video giving recommendations for books
that I didn't mention and even this link
to the John Bates science if you're
still looking for more advice on what
books people enjoyed and for some
recommendations go to the comment
section on my last video and I think
there's quite a lot of good
recommendations
there thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time